З чого складається телевізор, чайник чи стара друкарська машинка?
Для 29-річної Ганни з села Фастівець це не секрет.
Вона працює майстринею зі сортування електронного обладнання в Центрі управління відходами
і за рекордні 7 хвилин розбирає монітор від комп'ютера.
Ми відділили спочатку плату, потім відділяємо метал. Залежить від того,  який монітор. Є повністю складений з пластику, є гіпс, є ПВС.
Ми його сортуємо, відсортували і це йде на спалювання.
Саме тут в селі Фастівець, що за 60 кілометрів від Києва, розміщений склад Центру управління відходами.
І сюди привозили електронну техніку, яку в грудні 2020-го збирали у киян.
Тоді щовихідних у різних районах столиці працювали мобільні бригади і містяни могли безкоштовно здати відпрацьоване електрообладнання.
Для компанії це був експеримент, для киян  - можливість позбутись електронного непотребу без шкоди для довкілля.
Я ще ці купував просто на ОLХ. Покористувався, то треба ж їх утилізувати.
Гору електроніки від киян працівники вже давно розібрали.
Те, що нині на складі - застаріла техніка від бізнесу, банків чи державних установ.
Такі комерційні проєкти і дозволяють підприємству розвиватись.
Кожен пристрій вручну розбирається на пластик, метал, скло, дроти, плати.
В компанії запевняють, що 80% цієї сировини йде на вторинну переробку, а відтак стає новим товаром.
Решта спалюється, жодна деталь не потрапляє на сміттєзвалище.
На вішалки йдуть для одягу, каналізаційні труби...
У нас одна людина,  приватна особа, купувала пластик, вона для Укртелекому виготовляла ялинки для кріплення натяжки комунікацій дротів.
Це він виготовляв для них по замовленню Укртелекому. Всі інші речі… ми не дуже цікавимось.  У нас завдання продати пластик.
Втім, ринок вторсировини в Україні нестабільний. Компанії постійно доводиться шукати нових підрядників та перевіряти на доброчесність старих.
іше робили монітори для комп'ютерів чи корпуси принтерів. Тож його накопичують та чекають, коли на заводах запрацюють нові технології.
У нас зараз Харків просить пробну партію, ми відправили пластик, і він їм по хімічному складу підійшов,
і сподіваюсь, що вони будуть працювати з нами. І будемо готувати на відправку.
А ось найцінніший матеріал електротехніки - плати - накопичують і відправляють на переробку до Європи.
Там є заводи, які відділяють з них цінні метали, такі як золото, срібло.
Небезпечні батарейки також утилізують за кордоном, бо в Україні відповідних технологій немає.
Втім, такий експорт є нормальним ринковим процесом, кажуть в Асоціації підприємств у сфері поводження з небезпечними відходами.
Гірше, коли на українському ринку з утилізації відходів працюють недобросовісні гравці.
Так, асоціація перевірила близько двохсот ліцензіатів.
З них лише двадцять мають хоча б якесь обладнання для утилізації відходів.
Ми об'єднали підприємства, які мають власну матеріальну технічну базу.
Бо в 2014 році ми з'ясували, що є багато підприємств, які крім печатки і живого директора можливо нічого не мали.
А вони вигравали величезні тендери, отримували обсяги відходів, а де ділись далі  - це велика загадка.
Це загадка, яка мала б розв’язуватись поліцією, але не доходить…
Частково лад у сфері відходів має навести відповідне законодавство.
Так, улітку 2020 року у Верховній Раді у першому читанні був прийнятий проєкт закону про управління відходами.
Наразі його удосконалюють в екологічному комітеті.
Лише після ухвалення рамкового закону депутати зможуть прийняти й спеціалізовані закони, які вже роками зареєстровані в Раді.
Наприклад, про електронне і електричне обладнання, батарейки та акумулятори.
Ми закладаємо принцип "забруднювач платить", за яким той, хто імпортує чи виробляє продукцію в упаковці,
має створити організацію з розширеною відповідальністю виробника. Або індивідуально, або колективно.
Якщо виробник не робить цього, він має нести відповідальність.
Це закладається в законопроєкт. Але хочеться не нав'язати це виробнику,
а допомогти йому перейти максимально нормальним способом, без великого тиску.
На станції сортування "Україна без сміття" безкоштовно приймають як електроніку так і понад 40 видів різних побутових відходів,
які потім продають підприємствам-утилізовувачам чи великим заготівельникам на кшталт Центру управління відходами.
Попри велику популярність серед киян станція не самоокупна і живе за рахунок екосвідомого бізнесу, каже її засновниця Євгенія Аратовська.
Натомість у Європі подібні станції є привабливим бізнесом. Адже їх фінансують підприємства-виробники упаковки, пояснює Євгенія.
Тамтешнє законодавство зобов'язує їх щороку виконувати певні показники зі збору власної сировини.
Різниця лише у обсягах: в окремих країнах Європи виробники мають зібрати і переробити до 60% тари від виготовленої продукції.
В Україні можна почати і з меншої кількості і щороку її збільшувати, пропонує активістка. Та поки проєкт закону лояльний до виробників упаковки.
На жаль не прописано, на жаль цільові показники виконують не виробники товарів в тарі і упаковці,
а мають виконувати органи місцевого самоврядування.
Тобто у виробника немає зобов'язання фінансувати інфраструктуру, яка має збирати їх пакування, і це та помилка, яка має бути виправлена.
І фінансово, і організаційно відповідальність за налагодження збирання роздільного сміття має бути у виробників.
Саме тоді вони будуть зацікавлені і фінансувати цю сферу і відшкодовувати витрати заготівельників
і будуть дійсно виконувати цільові показники, бо інакше - штраф.
Не чекаючи закону, Євгенія вже планує розширюватись і відкриватиме нову сортувальну станцію в Києві.
За проєктом там будуть не лише сортувати сміття, але й запустять виробництво корисних речей з вторсировини,
аби відвідувачі одразу бачили, що можна з неї зробити.
Наприклад, робитимуть такі лавки, які в листопаді 2020 року "Україна без сміття" встановила в київському сквері.
На них пішло понад триста кілограмів пластикових кришечок.
Це така вже інфраструктура, яка має стати зразком для наслідування.
Тобто будь-яке місто  України, яке хоче почати культуру відповідального ставлення до відходів будувати,
ставить у себе таку саму станцію, облаштовує її.
Туди ходять діти на екскурсію і це вже початок чогось.
Коли людина знає, як сортувати, навіщо сортувати, скільки в Україні заводів переробки, то у неї вже з'являється мотивація.
У селі Фастівець, де живе і працює Ганна, сортувальних станцій немає. Втім її ставлення до сміття змінили півтора року роботи на складі.
Поміняла, дуже поміняла. Ми почали сортувати пластик.
То колись то викинули бутилку, пластмасу спалили. А зараз сортуємо. Набагато краще стало.
Розширюватись планує і Центр управління відходами.
Адже потік замовлень на утилізацію техніки не припиняється,
а з першим теплом обіцяють повторити безкоштовну акцію зі збору електроніки для киян.